the number of MEP s will shrink from 751  to 705 after brexit some or all of these  46 seats will be put into a reserve and  could be given to new countries joining  the block or kept to make the  institution smaller a target date of  2025 has been set for two Western Balkan  countries Serbia Montenegro to join the  European Union they need to meet certain  criteria including a free press and  fighting corruption 63 percent of  European websites don't let shoppers buy  from another EU country this is called  geo blocking parliament has voted to end  the discriminatory practice  an estimated 500,000 women living in the  EU have undergone female genital  mutilation members adopted a resolution  to step up prevention measures in all  policy areas parliament voted on whether  to keep the twice-yearly summertime  change some studies say it could have  negative health effects mep s want  further assessment of the issue  [Music]